i told you on wednesday's show that
susie and i my wife and i went to the
los angeles premiere of american
underdog and it is a beautiful movie and
it is about the story of kurt and brenda
warner and when kurt went on his magical
carpet ride
from unknown to super bowl champion and
super bowl mvp the whole world was
saying this is a movie it should be a
movie and now it is and it's out on
christmas day
and zachary levi plays kurt and anna
paquin plays brenda and they are awesome
in it and i could not be happier that
this film that is perfect for our times
and what everybody needs in our world is
a good feel-good movie good sports movie
coming out on christmas day and joining
me here to talk about all of that are my
two dear friends who's
whose life is right there on the silver
screen kurt and brendan warner good to
see you guys it's just good to be here
and you don't know how happy it makes us
for you to say it's it's a good movie
you know
i know you said that you know backstage
that you know you're kind of a little
bit concerned sometimes when you see
friends
well i mean because you know it's hard
because
you have friends and
we've had a number of people see it and
of course they're like oh it's good and
you know a lot of times you're like well
what are they gonna say right um and so
when people see it and see it in the
movie theater and just listening to you
uh on your show yesterday
like genuinely like hey guys it's good
it's good it's good i'm excited because
it's good and i don't have to sit here
and tell kurt no it's good
but how you know how good that makes us
feel because
um that's what you want at the end of
the day is you want people to connect to
this movie you want them to be excited
about this movie and
you want to make a good movie you don't
want it to be something that's out there
forever and people go eh is it well i
mean
you'll know if people are telling you
the truth because
if they go higher register on you like i
that was a good movie you know like
that's
that's when you should get a little bit
concerned you know like no
no
no it was really good
that's the problem i genuinely mean it's
a beautiful movie and it's
what is it like
brenda and
yuker2 about seeing such a personal
story being told like this for the whole
world to see well i feel vulnerable and
you know me well enough that that is not
what i'm comfortable being yes that is
not your default it is not and yet
you know i really believe it's going to
be worth that um because we show the
good the bad and the ugly about what
real life is and i think people relate
to that i really want a single mom
sitting there watching it think if she
can do this and she waited for someone
to look at her that way
i i hope that single mom waits and i
also hope that people that you know lose
somebody like i've lost people in my
life i hope that they just can take a
deep breath and think okay i can get
through it there is another side um you
know so much is happening in this world
right now even watching tornado footage
in the movie yes um you know people are
picking up and cleaning up all over the
country i mean there's so many things to
relate to
so
even though i had to be vulnerable
and share it all i really do think it's
going to make a difference in people's
lives so that makes me you know know
it's worth it how about you correct i
mean it's you know again it starts with
people liking it and once people like it
you take a deep breath and you know so
much of our journey we i remember us
kind of going why why do we have to go
through this why do we have to be here i
know brenda obviously with some of the
personal stuff
why why me and you see that in the movie
and you know not that we still wanted to
go through it or right now it's okay
that we went through it but you get to
this point you go
well maybe this is why maybe we've got
an opportunity here with this movie and
our story to impact people and to
encourage people and inspire and
challenge people in different ways with
where they find themselves right now you
mention it
how many people find themselves in an
underdog role now
that never thought they would be here
three years ago
and so that's kind of our hope and i i'm
excited about that as much as you have
to put stuff out there and and hope that
you know the people involved do the
right thing with the movie and they
share the right story and people connect
with it we really do believe that this
story has a chance to uh to really
impact people and touch people kurt and
brenda warner here in person on the rich
eisen show and to me what makes a
terrific sports movie is obviously
there's got to be a someone to root for
check that box
uh then there's a love story
there's always going to be a love story
in there and and check that box and then
there's frequently uh in sports movies
more often than not a father-son story
and this movie checks the love story and
the father-son story
in the same box yeah and it's a
beautiful thing did you were you guys
concerned to make zack sort of a focus
of this film from the very beginning
when you saw that i was not concerned i
didn't think this movie could be made
without that because what you see in
this movie is to me he's the glue
that breaks down
the walls that both of us have put up
you know where i'm going and how i see
myself at that point in time in our
journey and where brenda's had and what
she had been through at that point in
time in her journey you know we both had
like you know is this really going to
work for both of us and it was zach that
was the glue behind that but to me
the bigger part of it as you mentioned a
lot of sports movies it's
the sun
chasing after you know dad's
you know ghost or whatever like you know
i i want that you know him to be proud
of me and i want to show him that i
could do this
what i love about this story is i was
doing that with my son i was chasing
after what he was showing us and what
the life that he was living and making
him proud of me and and we were both
inspired by him you know i think too
often we feel like well i'm the older
one i'm the father i'm the leader i'm
supposed to
impact and inspire you know my kids
and that to me was what was really cool
about this story is that it was that was
inspiring us throughout this this whole
journey and you know we can be impacted
and we can be inspired by anybody it
doesn't matter their age it doesn't
matter the role that we play um when you
look at the life of of our son and what
he's taught us
that to me was a crucial part of this
movie that was different to me
than most sportsman no i don't but i
mean kurt fell in love with my kids
before he fell in love with me and i get
it like they're easy to fall in love
with and i'm not i wasn't um i'm not
easy so
when he fell in love with the kids and
we'd continue to date um we'd get ready
to break up over something and he would
say well i get the kids and i think no
the boyfriend never
never
so suddenly he wanted to work it out and
uh we made up and you know life went on
but um that's the love that that's the
kind of man that i want to marry you
know that falls in love with my kids the
way he did and keep in mind he was 21
years old
what 21 year old starts dating a
divorced mother of two
that's 25 years old former marine
cheated on divorce like
he was asking for it you know he really
was but um that's the kind of man i
married yes and a child with needs yes
as well
you know and and the boy who plays zach
in this film is remarkable remarkable
just remarkable and so so it's just
again it's just a beautiful thing to
watch unfold curt and brenda warner here
on the rich eisen show another uh aspect
of a sports movie uh that makes it
terrific checks at boxes dennis quaid
was you know was vermeel is open i mean
who plays mike martz in the movie
kelly
was phenomenal was mike as really
opposed to your presence there as he is
in the film or do they play that up a
little bit no
he was and yeah i mean
the stuff in the movie you know is all
obviously as it says based on true story
and yeah i mean you know i can't tell
you exactly what happened behind the
scenes yes but a lot of that is my
interpretation based on my interaction
with mike martin so yeah so a lot of the
stuff you see in the movie uh that
checks every box of of what really
happened is you know mike really trying
to push me because you know here's the
guy coming from grocery store and arena
football that nobody knows anything
about and he's never going to get to see
me between the lines until
i'm between the lines with the ball in
my hands and so
his goal was to go let me see if this
guy can hack it with as much pressure as
i can put on him every single day i mean
just to kind of go beyond that i
remember doing an interview about week
four of the season and it was marshall
and isaac and tory and
and all the the skill players on that
team i remember the interviewer asking
them okay did you guys know kurt was was
going to be this good and it was
marshall i think that responded and he's
like we actually thought kurt was
terrible because every day in practice
all he did was get yelled at you know
all we heard was him getting yelled at
time and time again so
you know none of us had any idea that he
was any good because that's what we
heard every single day and so that was
uh very true to form to to what i felt
like and what i was going through in
those moments what was it like for you
when he was going through that magic
carpet right well i mean kurt so easily
easily liked and he would call and say
this man hates me and i think what is
wrong with that man because nobody hates
him i mean it you just can't and so i
thought something's going on that kurt's
not seeing you know and
this whole time watching him play
football and me not being a sports fan
or a football fan
you know it was all like watching him
um try and just get that opportunity so
if this was the man that was gonna stop
that i mean it just didn't make sense
how he couldn't like him so i thought
maybe he isn't that good you know maybe
this guy sees that he isn't that good so
for now to understand and look back and
you see it in the movie for the reason
why he treated him like that you know to
to bring up um you know who what kind of
man he really is and what kind of player
he was going to be now it makes sense um
but during the time i thought who is
this who is this
man yeah and i think that's the part
that i love about the movie maybe the
best is that you know there were
different characters in the movie that
when they're first introduced you're
like i don't like this guy
but as the movie progresses you come to
understand everybody's role
in getting me to where i ended up and
that's what this movie is so much about
is that it's not about the you know
where i ended up because everybody knows
that story it's about how i got there
and and who shaped me
along the way from zach to brenda to you
know my college coach and there's some
of my high school coach mixed into my
college coach um and then mike martz and
dick vermeel and all those people that
had to step in in their role because
without their role
you know even at times when we didn't
like their role
their role was key in shaping the person
that that i would become well it's
interesting that you would say that kurt
because um
the guy who plays mooch is a very
handsome man and i don't know you know
he's known he's known in my my family as
a good-looking mooch yeah
no i told
you know nobody really needs to know
that he's that good looking or he used
to be like that that's a casting choice
that i don't it was a good catching tool
i thought you could have put your foot
down because i thought that was a good
casting choice you know i mean and again
even guys like mooch as much fun as we
have
with mooch i love in in short roll in
the movie but i love the role in the
movie because it's it's so key to this
whole thing i mean
me getting cut and
that scene there i think is a beautiful
scene because uh you don't see very many
pro athletes do what what i did in that
moment um but the dialogue between mooch
and i is that
how accurate was that because i don't
know we bust so many stones about this
yeah that wasn't fully accurate it
wasn't mooch that actually cut minor
specificated decisions and so we didn't
necessarily have that conversation
then right but we've had that
conversation since then okay and you
know as much always goes no you cut you
you know i didn't cut you you cut you
and
there's it's 100 true that i did cut me
you know that i wasn't ready for that
moment that i needed more seasoning and
timing yeah um and so even like a moment
like that that you're bummed and you
know again we always blame mooch for it
um it was something that i needed at
that point in time to develop into the
player that i would be when i when i got
back with the ram so all of that stuff
and again
there's truth in all of that it's just
how and when and and how it played out
to to tie it into the movie which which
i think they did beautifully wow it's so
great i'm so happy for you guys
i really am because it is a beautiful
movie it's so
well representative of you and who you
guys are as a couple and as a as a you
know parenting group which you are
together you know and
and you know uh um and it ties
everything all together you know
treasure house which you have
going on built in in the uh in the
phoenix area um where folks like zach
can come and live self-sufficient lives
and your guys success as a couple and as
a a family unit has led to that
i honestly it gets me all
choked up what does your family think
about this movie uh you know um we have
seven kids and yeah when they all watch
it um kurt and i are kind of shocked
because you know they tease us like all
kids tease parents they're so tired of
the stories they've had to hear stories
you know we walked uphill to school you
know in the snow all those kind of
stories so when they watch it they seem
to appreciate us you know a little bit
more like i didn't realize that when you
told that story that that's what it felt
like that the movie does that for them
and you know to to know that treasure
house which is a residential facility
for adults with intellectual disability
that's my baby because i realize that's
what we're going to leave behind you
know we're leaving behind a place that
is just the first of hopefully many that
give these young people a full life and
i'm raising seven kids i want them all
to have a full life it's all going to
look differently for each child but he
deserves it as much as anybody else so
that is my honor to you know be able to
say we put our mark on that on that
place and we need them all over the
country because there's other parents
you know sitting in other states going
what about my child what about what
what's my future um as a young adult
with disability
where are my peers where is my community
where is my tribe and so that's our
calling and we know it and our kids know
it that that's what we're going to leave
behind yeah i mean it's been
you know the best part of it is is
watching our kids see the movie and be
able to see us
in a different light
it was also the challenge of the movie
because um you know for instance like my
dad my dad's not really a part of this
movie even though he's an unbelievable
part of our lives and our kids lives and
we have a great relationship but
that wasn't the story that we went down
because obviously i was raised in a
single
parent household with my mom and the
connection with brenda and so um you
know it's the beautiful part of it and
sometimes the tough part is you don't
get to tell
the whole story you've got to figure out
the right story and uh the great thing
at the end of the day is i believe we
got the right story in a story that's
really going to connect with people you
did man you did too you both did i mean
it really is again susie and i we walked
out of the theater feeling good about
ourselves we felt good about our family
we felt good about the world
and we also did have a similar reaction
that your kids had like because we've
heard your story you know we know you
we've had dinner we've hung out we know
each other and it's just like wow
okay
that's the way it felt when you were
going through it
and then we would see
video too we're like yeah kurt made some
good throws and well marshall was that
fast you know like it really is
amazing seeing how
it it nails it it just sticks the
landing and you know i mean there's a
bunch of people who haven't heard your
story before or haven't seen it or have
heard about it but they're they were too
young to remember it and
so you're leaving that too yeah amazing
honestly i could not be happier for you
guys you know and we couldn't be happier
that you're happy i appreciate
that i would have been happier instead
of you know you know steve levy being
the guy sitting next to stewart on
sportscenter in the movie it could have
been me but you know uh i mean
maybe you just needed to bash me back
then like this team's done for maybe you
didn't say that so we couldn't
[Music]
i thought he did a great job with vermeo
um you know because you look at the
little mannerisms as you talked about
like with zach and myself and um just
like the hands uh in that moment where
we'll rally around kurt warner and play
good football just some of those little
things i thought he did a great job and
you know the bottom line is you want to
hear from coach fermio like yeah we
talked to coach coach how did we do i i
do we get and he's like oh dennis did a
great job he actually called him and
sent him some wine so that means that
means he did a good job
yeah tweet about it so he was happy with
it but yeah i thought i thought he did a
great job with that that's great yeah
that's so awesome yeah and zachary
nailed nailed you uh did dana paquin get
you down i think so i would okay i think
her portrayal shows
somebody that you would want in your
foxhole and that you would also want to
have a beer with so i think she got me i
really do and you know again i'm not an
easy person so the fact that she cared
enough to try and figure out why
i believe what i believe that says
something about her you know she cared
enough to get it right and she did and i
believe she got both sides
because i as brenda said sometimes i
think she's always projected you know
tough strong former marine and that's
how a lot of people have seen her on the
outside
but i've always seen there's a whole
other side to her you know it's that
vulnerable side it's the side that's you
know the mom and the love and all of
that stuff that sometimes gets hidden
when they just show the headlines and i
thought that's what anna nailed so well
is you got both sides of it you get the
tough strong but then you also get the
vulnerable side that that completes who
brenda is and i think really shows her
in the light that she deserves to be
shown in terrific it's so great before i
i i let you go um the choice to leave
out of the movie the moment where dick
vermeel uh during uh august kicked jeff
wilkins in the leg
uh i'm wondering
you know why that wound up on the
cutting room floor occurred um or that
didn't happen that's just yeah yeah not
that i know that did not happen well i
mandated to ask you what you think of
urban meyer's uh
firing
i mean on wednesday by the way during
your premiere right exactly during the
premiere you came out you probably came
out of the theater like next morning i
actually found out the next morning
i was like what just happened and what
was the story
but we've talked about it you know a
number of times now
i still can't wrap my head around these
stories that i've heard i still in my
mind go that that can't
be legit that can't have really had
happened uh you know in numerous
different ways and so i mean i'm not
surprised after all of this that he's
fired right um you know you just say to
yourself it's about time if all of this
stuff is true but it's just hard to
fathom that a coach goes into a
situation has coached as long as he had
has had as much success as he's had and
all of these different things of really
how he's treated people because to me
being a leader on a team and being a
head coach is all about how you treat
people and getting people to go to
battle for you and and
you know and want to run through a wall
for you and um
this just stuff just kind of
flabbergasted me that that we keep
hearing
these kind of stories yeah it struck me
that that was the conversation we were
having on on game day morning throughout
the the
entire year where he had been hired and
then went through the draft and then
everything else that was going on was
how he would handle the losing and it
looked like he handled losing the way
that apparently he did at ohio state it
just he spread the losses of nine out
over seven years as opposed to 11 in 13
weeks
and if that's the way he handled losing
in college that
just that's not the way you can do that
in the nfl well i i will say i've seen
this game change people i've seen this
happen is that they're so used to
winning
uh that once it starts to turn the other
direction
they've never had to learn how to handle
it and you know we talk about that all
the time you got to be able to know
how to deal with those kind of
situations because the nfl is completely
different whether you're a player or a
coach in some guys it takes time some
guys never get there where they can
fully understand
their part in losing because they're not
used to to having that part well in the
opposite end of the spectrum it's your
guy's story on the silver screen uh on
christmas day so uh congrats thanks
thank you love you guys
and you bet uh have a happy merry
christmas and you really liked it
i really didn't like two enthusiastic
thumbs up and and again again it's when
the conversations we had susie and i
which is like one of those things is
just like yes we know them yes we love
them yes we know their story but that in
its own right
is a beautiful movie you know and a
great sports movie on top of it it's in
the mix it's in the mix it's terrific
kurt and brenda warner everyone should
see american underdog in a theater near
you on christmas day hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here